[Music]  this was something  i could never have seen coming  [Music]  it was really helpful to listen to tom  talking about the mischief because  she's another version of loki but it was  important to make sure she was  unique because she's silvie she's not  loki  what exactly makes a loki a loki  independence authority  style awful  [Music]  loki comes face to face with sylvie and  wants to know more  a few questions you're in my way  the audience will be intrigued by  sylvie's arc and the back story  it really just sets the groundwork for  this character  the universe wants to break free so it  manifests chaos  like me sylvia is going to leap into the  mcu with  extraordinary energy people are going to  love it  expect the unexpected  you